[Musique]
l'udc a dépêché un faux signal
jones et squeeze on se retrouve
aujourd'hui pour une nouvelle vidéo sur
scène trop 3 autrement dit c'est trop
the third parce que vous avez été
nombreux à me demander de refaire une
vidéo sur scène ce trou pour vous
montrer encore plus de trucs géniaux
dans le jeu comme notamment c'est super
grand qui ne durent généralement
l'ennemi en une balle flaques de sang
alors je vous ai concocté comment on
fait déjà je me sens plus longtemps que
j'ai pas joué d'accord merci pour ma
voiture
voilà donc lycée en fait j'ai pris les
armes que vous et qui selon moi vous
intéresseront le plus donc missiles
predator on va les tester ça juste après
lors ce mollusque le togo 13 donc c'est
un sniper l'autoroute 15 le cyber
destructeur et lazy guns en gros voilà
je pense que ça vous plaira et bien sûr
les appoints apocalypse plus que bas
mais je trouve ça vraiment marqué les
modos et steed et de faire des espèces
de 2 points monstrueux c'est assez
marrant faut bien le dire alors c'est
parti donc qu'est ce qu'on va pouvoir
faire j'ai ma petite idée en tête
grenchen comme gérer cyprien alors
attendez up en bus est sorti tout seul
du match quand est sorti cash
alors donc on va faire des émissions là
je sais pas ce que c'est j'ai dû en
faire une depuis que je joue au centro
et j'ai pas joué à san siro depuis la
dernière vidéo je vous avais fait parce
que je joue un double jeu tout
simplement donc on va on va faire fraude
à l'assurance est partie j'espère que ce
sera quand même assez amusant que ça en
fait plutôt fun mais j'espère qu'on aura
l'occasion de tester ses superbes jambes
plutôt rigolote et pour vous en
exclusivité totale j'ai eu l'idée en fin
de je vais partager une technique si
vous avez des conflits avec un prof
super technique pour que le prof
derrière vous dire vous aime bien on va
dire pour pas être grossier il suffit et
ben en fait c'est à dire que vous à
manger pour le proprement un petit
service en l'occurrence moi je devais
donner une copie un mec c'était ma
mission
elle m'a fait soldat tu devras rendre
cette copie à alexandre qui fait partie
de ta clash devra le rendrait lui
indiquer les instructions ci dessous
alexandre va te faire [ __ ] je veux que
tu recopies ça sur des copies doux et
pas sur des copies c'est un bon en gros
c'est son problème il a fait de voir sur
des copies simple et pas sur des copies
doubles
donc du coup je lui ai donné nana est
allé me voir après un autre court dalmat
fait ouais alors tu les a bien donné
travail trop [ __ ] j'ai dit oui je vais
donner des depuis elle me kiffe depuis
que je dors en quoi me dis rien je fais
rien ou quoi me dit rien france absurde
je l'aï le sujet doit faire quoi
alors apparemment sont déjà jusqu'aux
truc bleus en tout cas si cette astuce
marche pour vous ça serait plutôt cool
puisque moi ça a bien marché et je peux
vous dire c'est vraiment amusant de voir
un prof qui détestent et vous lui rendez
un tout petit service bon faut dire
qu'elle saigne une prof très naïve et
hop tout d'un coup elle tombe amoureuse
de vous faire mal voir la machine sa
gueule alors c'est parti
je comprends juste pas du tout ce qu'il
faut faire apparemment voilà un endroit
bon c'est on est tous mais on est tombé
sur la mission la plus chiante du jeu
j'ai désolé je sais pas trop ce qu'il
faut faire de blessé dans cette zone
bonus te donnera un multiplicateur x 2
de blessés dans cette zone bonus non
mais non il y avait un truc là-bas non
mais qu'est ce qu'il faut faire mais
qu'est ce qu'il faut faire a lui aussi
joué en jeunes de bale études je vais
vous dire en haut à droite la d1 fois
j'ai dit en bas à droite j'ai remarqué
l'indicateur mais à oui ok faut pas que
je me jette genre comme ça ah voilà
c'est ça voilà c'est ça faut que je me
jette avec une touche à la csn blair
vite les devis annonce ce point de jeter
sous les roues mais je lui garde un fois
je vous avais dit que l'indicateur de
respecter situé en bas oh mais enfin
messieurs les bus les gendarmes
qu'est ce que c'est que cette merde hein
depuis quand vous écrasez les passants
quoi ah merde j appelais sûr
un jeton à on voit carrément et des
dents de la voiture enfin j'ai fait
tomber l'aude avec moi non mais moins
chaud ouais je battant ate doute une
touche la revanche ce que je peux même
pas le tarp et on a touché le bon bref
je vais vous dire oui donc l'indicateur
de respect les thésards il est situé en
haut à droite et n'ont pas droit parce
que j'avais dit comme un coût qu'il
était sûr bas à droite et jusqu'où vous
avez tous regardés vous avez vu matt est
en train de faire il est situé en bas à
droite alors que non c'était ma tête en
bas à droite vous à regarder et en fait
non c'est un joli crcc haut à droite
voilà vous verrez bien tout à l'heure ça
lui allait au mais enfin monsieur bon je
pense pas qu'on va y arriver on n'est
qu'à trente et un mille sur 59
ça n'a pas trop le faire comme ça ouais
ouais ouais jolie oui oui on vous dit
oui
un valet de toit ou os est combo le luxe
la race et des arnaqueurs sa boucle
moi je voulais howey c'est vraiment
complètement débile c'est incroyable
les mecs concret j'ai eu deux raids
comme sacré enflé pour imposante et
récemment que ça par contre si cher je
peux pas taper les jours bon je pense
qu'on va abandonner allez hop ça va
aller plus vite
dakar comment ces kits activités on va
quitter yes et je vais vous montrer une
petite démo de comment faire la voix de
du comment il s'appelle zee quelque
chose qui est dense être 3 c'est un mec
qui a une voix complètement robotisée et
je vais activer cette fois complètement
robotisée à partir de maintenant voilà
normand l'âge devrait avoir la voix
complètement robotisés
et juste avant une pure bois vraiment
magnifique et je le dis elle j'ai appris
à faire cette voie il ya yahya baya tout
simplement quand j'ai fait la vidéo sur
sûr que j'en donne intrigue mais enfin
où j'ai tenté de faire un gameplay comme
kutcher traîne d'ailleurs on va revenir
sur ce sujet a juste après il faut que
je parle pour voir cette vidéo au bas
voilà je peux taper avril j'ai quitté et
là avant il serait encore la voix c'est
une voix super bien robotisés ça fait un
bel deux tribus
bref je la vie active à partir de nom et
je dois dire que c'est plutôt sympa
comme moi de faire un truc aussi aussi
débile enfin d'avoir enfin si t'es sympa
c'est que le fait en fait il est né sur
espèce de cet islam et la s1 cet enfant
de micro et ça fait 7 voix auto tune et
c'est super sympa d'ailleurs on dirait
que java colonel royal quand je fais ça
connais tu regarde cette vidéo comme
s'il regardera la vidéo enfin bon donc
on va se diriger vers autre chose et
jouit donc je reviens à propos de l'acq
2 conservant que jordan les avions été
très mitigé donc j'ai des critiques très
constructive qui a été négative
bon forcément sa barre ça m'attriste et
noir sont assez c'est toujours pas super
agréable m6 s'est construit tout ça de
bon je vais pas trop mal pris au jeu
décidé de laisser la vidéo malgré tout
vu que bhl n'est quand même pas mal de
temps à la faire et à et je voulais
préciser que le gameplay enfin la vidéo
c'était vraiment juste le gameplay que
je faisais comme coach jardin j'ai
essayé un peu de dope la jirga pas de
talent days c'est à dire d'arrivée tout
ça le but c'était justement d'arriver en
adoptant l'attitude que jordan à faire
un bon gameplay voilà au cas où pour
ceux qui aimeraient qu'ils n'auraient
pas à pas très bien compris ton et que
j'ai pas très nettes de mon truc voilà
c'est juste ça bon j'ai laissé la vidéo
mais bon vous inquiétez pas je peux en
faire d'autres comme ça c'est juste un
petit délire que je me suis imposé à moi
même et on va faire quoi et ce corse
ah ça c'est marrant ça la tête de chat
ça c'est marrant alors on va y aller un
bout p vous avez quand même on est dans
cette foule il veut que je fasse tout
buts que je tourne et que je le reprenne
dans le centre mais attendez r d dans
cet euro les gars là ont fait demi tour
sur notre propre route quoi se sont sans
tarder du temps du 2e rang les poussent
un ouf
ok let's go donc c'est je crois que les
preuves c'est une tête de chien tu sais
plus très bien je suis très bien ce
qu'il ya c'est je crois que sais je sais
plus je sais plus je crois que si je
sais plus voilà c'est exactement ça je
crois que si je sais pas en tout cas
c'est parti j'espère que ça va être
plutôt a besoin mais il me souviens que
c'était une des épreuves vraiment très
fun sur fun et ça fait bizarre
pour ceux qui jouent à jassem soit passé
un pouvoir getac à 12 allez voir vous
allez juste plus réussir à conduire
c'est impressionnant comme la
maniabilité est réduite sur un os allez
je vous montre le messie le predator sur
gt r c'est un énorme rêve qu'elle reste
correspond à l'abri on va se tuer avec
ces partis mais tu prenais à tort c'est
ça que je vous disais la parodie c'est
juste là et si on veut
l'idée on fait comment à
bah voilà c'est exactement comme ça je
trouve ah non ah bon écoutez moi vous
aurez vu lui ces prédateurs doivent
c'est plutôt marrant quand même d'avoir
foutu
en fait ils se foutent vraiment la
gueule ils se foutent gratuitement de la
gueule de tout le monde doit être trois
assez marrant les soutes de la gueule de
tron il souffre de la gueule de 2 à 2
call of duty enfin call of duty
excusez-moi si xamax en france et 2
battlefield 3 et 2 assez marrant bon je
vais vous montrer de trois armes en
attendant avant d'aller à stephen king
épreuve il y en a qui doivent être
impatient d'aller à venise que j ai
regardé le lui à merde
ah mais ça ça gagne mais normalement en
fait ce qui se passe c'est que les
ennemis voulaient remettre ça sur la
tronche ça fait exactement pareil
et en fait après ils viennent ils
deviennent durs que tekken 6 pas de
danse poésie qui envoya sa ensuite il ya
un autre truc aussi qu'il faut mettre
mon mari si vive bien je sais qu à moi
regardez regardez
holmes c'est incroyable mais les mecs
qu'une idée de faire ça ils sont tout
simplement incroyables cdg divers mais
est ce que quelqu'un de l'idée de faire
un truc que tu tires sur le mec comme ça
ça te bouffe comme ça un requin sort du
sol et le bouquetin mais franchement je
trouve ça vraiment quand même assez
incroyable et vous je vous aime pas vous
dire des brûlures dans ce drôle en fait
votre taf
bon mes gants sont en panne
la pub il met 1 à bac en même temps j'ai
cru qu'il y avait plus de piles vous
pensez qu'il ya des piles dans ses gants
peut-être que les packs sont des
batteries bref j'en sais rien alors bon
allez on va faire cette petite épreuve
et ensuite on va stopper la vidéo alors
je vais rentrer dans dans la voiture qui
se situe juste ici qui est une
d'accord c'est une marque nom réel bon
en même temps je pense pas qu'ils ont le
droit de faire des marques telles je
sais pas c'est jouable alors let's go
quand on aurait dit que justin
timberlake un peu regardé j'ai agressé
justin timberlake alors c'est parti et
mégots cta vous avez déménagé
j'espère c'est pas trop loin attention
papapapa fin
pinda psg est vraiment un crabe désolé
pour les graphismes et pour la qualité
de la vidéo mais je like enjeu étant
donné que c'est un jeu très gourmand
centro et pourquoi j'aime beaucoup plus
bas c'est parce que j'avais envie d'être
fun dans un jeu fun ça me paraît plutôt
logique de l'automne donc j'ai essayé de
maquiller la perruque bleue qu'un abonné
m'avait donné à la paris games week
d'ailleurs un gros big up à lui si je
suis toujours mes vidéos je sais pas
peut-être en tout cas bizet ou alors
c'est parti j'aimerais bien y aller
et pour ceux qui tiennent au courant de
ce que fait warteck il allait à paris
aujourd'hui donc vendredi et l'arrivée
hier soir jeudi et est donc il a
rencontré certains d'entre vous je ne
sais pas si on a d'entre vous qui était
acquis en vouloir tech dans ce cas ça
c'est super sympa de sa part je trouve
de vous avoir prévenus comme ça parce
que je crois que c'était un voyage avec
son école et ça c'est une arme gel aussi
alors c'est parti
mardi let's go away je disais bas c'est
plutôt sympa il ya même quelqu'un m'a
dit qui est qui lui a demandé à il avait
sa ps3 et sa manette et lui a demandé de
dédicaces et sur la ps3 est un fait
troublant indélébile et sur la manette
de console et legacy war klm alors on
dimanche au moins 100 euros alors je
sais plus
pour sa nouvelle star chinoise est ce
que tu as plein la gueule vraiment belle
merde
ah oui mais attention cependant sortis
des soutes de laquelle de vraiment
impressionnant au lauragais 1 1
oui je le cache pas d'ailleurs up
maintenant larmes elle va être incluse
voilà c'est à chacun ensuite l'armée
shop boys
d'accord non c'était de danse à l'espace
ok oui j'y pense que c'est bon ok on se
casse aux mères du monde quelques
dollars oh non vous êtes sérieux sur ces
huiles à base de bois vous à lui en plus
il est tombé il a vu j'ai bloqué je
pensais pouvoir te laisse alors c'est
parti
alors j'ai d'abord ce qu'on a je sais
pas ce qu'on obtient sur nokia quelque
chose ou pas
alors il me voyez ce que l on aura droit
à nana oui d'accord ça permet de
contrôler plus de quartiers on ne gagne
plus de trucs plus d'argent pour avoir
écouté
j'espère que tu commentaires et vous
aura plu est rien pour vous faire
plaisir je vais remettre un pull pas sur
ces deux personnes qui ma foi on voit là
et excuse si on met ça au pied de la
voiture ça fait quelque chose
non ça fait rien ça ferme c'est dommage
ça fait rien ah ouais à l'intérieur la
vie c'est le dr un teaser 1
en pauvres comme tu dois avoir mal aux
le fail
ouch ça ça doit faire mal bon bah écoute
et j'espère cette petite vidéo vous aura
plu je vous invite à vous abonner à
machete pas trop gourmands world jolie
son père lequel de mes prochaines vidéos
enfin patron des prochaines sorties
vidéo et et puis voilà c'est tout
j'espère que cette vidéo vous en a plus
en tout cas moi je suis fatigué et c'est
les vacances messieurs dames j'ai
profité pleinement de ses vacances pour
geeker pour nous reposer vraiment
puisque je suis bien fatigué en
attendant j'espère que ça vous aura plu
à dubaï et à bientôt
je baisse ma paire week